اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء استعاده
قوات الامن البرازيليه سيطره على القصر
الرئاسي والمحكمه العليا ومقر الكونجرس
واعتقلت العشرات وكان محتاجون مؤيدون
للرئيس البرازيلي السابق جانيير
بوليسينارو اقتحموا القصر الرئاسيه ومقر
الحكومه ومبنى البرلمان ومبنى المحكمه
الفيدراليه في العاصمه البرازيليه رفضا
لتنصيب الرئيس لولا ديسيلو‬»
هذا اصدر الرئيس البرازيلي لولدي سيلفا
عمران بتدخل القوات الاتحاديه لسيطره على
الاوضاع في العاصمه بعد عمليه اقتحام وصف
الرئيس سيلفا ما جرى بالاعمال الهمجيه
وتعاهد بمحاسبه كل من شارك وخطط ومولى ما
وصفه بالاعتداء المباشر على القانوني
والديمقراطيه وفدت وكاله رويترز ان مكتب
المدعي العام اصدر امرا باعتقال وزير
الامن العام
انطلقت في السودان المرحله النهائيه
للعمليه السياسيه بعد شهر من توقيع
الاتفاق الايطالي وقالت الاليه الثلاثيه
الميسره للحوار والتي تتالف من الاتحاد
الافريقي ومجموعه ايجاد وبعثت الامم
المتحده الى الاتفاقه حاضيه بدعم كبير من
القوى السياسيه والمجتمع الدولي والاقليمي
وقال رئيس مجلس السياده ان المؤسسه
العسكريه لن تتراجع عما تعهدت به
بالانسحاب من المشهد السياسي وتسليم قياده
مرحله الانتقال السياسي للمدنيين
وكانت قوى الحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه قالت انها اوقفت اللقاءات غير
المباشره مع مجموعه الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي وقال مبارك اردول الناطق
الرسمي باسم الكتله الى الاتفاق الايطاليه
لشكل الحالي مرفوض وتعاهد بتحريك الشارع
لاسقاطه
نفى المتحدث باسم قياده المنطقه الشرقيه
بالجيش الاوكراني تصريحات الروسيه التي
تتحدث عن مقتل 600 جندي الاوكراني في
كراماتوست مشددا على ان الجيش الروسيه لا
يملك القدرات الكافيه لتوجيه ضربات بتلك
الدقه وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قد
اعلنت ان قواتها نفذت ضربه انتقاميه ضد
القوات الاوكرانيه فكره ردا على هجوم
مكيفكا بمقاطعه الدونات ليله راس السنه
واضافت الوزاره انضربه ادت الى مقتل 600
عسكريه اوكرانيا في المدينه
اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه اجراء صفقه
ناجحه لتبادل الاسرى مع روسيا اطلق
بموجبها صلاح 50 جنديا نوكرانيا مقابل عدد
مماثل من العسكريين الروس
في كوسوفو منظمه حزب سيربس كاليستا مظاهره
جنوبيه البلاد لتمديد باطلاق شرطي نار على
شاب و طفل من الاقليه اولامس وطالب
المتظاهرون في بلده شتربتسا بمحاسبه
الشرطي
ومنع تكرار مثل هذه الحوادث
وقال الرئيس الصربي انها قوات حفظ السلام
التي يقودها حلف شمال الاطلسي رفض الطلب
بلاده بعوده عناصر من الجيش الصربي الى
كوسوفو
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]